American Horror Story has never shied
away from tackling controversial topics
the hit FX show will do whatever it
takes to torment terrorize and tantalize
you and needless to say things get
extreme here are some of the most
controversial American Horror Story
moments of all time season 1 of American
Horror Story is full of twisted violence
that's become a show stock-in-trade
but there's one moment that's always
stood out as particularly shocking in
the episode piggy piggy we see Tate
Langdon played by Evan Peters carrying
out a school shooting and gunning down
15 of his fellow students the on-screen
massacre gave many viewers flashbacks to
the horrific tragedy at Columbine High
School in 1999 after the episode aired
the Atlantic's Richard Lawson wrote it's
more than a little tasteless in a hey
this you know actually happened kind of
way obviously everything on the show if
done in real life is insanely terrible
but this particular set piece seemed so
deliberately exact there was a
particular event or events that they
were trying to directly evoke and that's
just cruel set in the 1960s the second
season of American Horror Story takes us
to the fictional mental health facility
Briarcliff Manor and one of its patients
really outraged some viewers what's your
name I hear you caused quite a
disturbance tonight some anti-semitic
remarks set you off in the episode I am
Anne Frank part one a woman claiming to
be an Frank shows up at Briarcliff
and some people just weren't having it
Rolling Stone described Hallie Keefer
wrote that next time we see her the
woman is writing in her journal in the
Briarcliff common room because she's an
Frank her journal is even named kitty Oh
Lord and Frank was a real person it just
isn't done am I being too delicate about
this some viewers argue that the show
was never trying to depict the real Anne
Frank but rather a mentally ill woman
who merely thought she was Anne Frank
Ryan Murphy worked that angle in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
claiming the Anne Frank thing was always
interesting to me because after the war
there were many women who came forward
after that diary in
said well I'm the real Anne Frank and
they were struck down many of them were
found to be mentally ill and suffering
from schizophrenia plenty of people took
issue with a scene in hotel the fifth
season of American Horror Story in the
season premiere a heroin addict named
Gabriel checks into the hotel Cortez and
soon suffers a terrible fate you know
what it's your lucky day
Mama's feeling magnanimous shortly after
he gets to his room Gabriel has a
horrific encounter with the addiction
demon a monstrous entity with some
sadistic sexual appetites after watching
the scene Cosmopolitan's Danielle
Henderson was absolutely beside herself
writing that to say this scene was
disturbing is an understatement
conservative watchdog group Parents
Television Council sharply criticized
the episode claiming that it's an
unbelievably explicit combination of sex
and violence honestly it's hard to argue
with that one in a letter to subscribers
PTC President Tim winter wrote that the
episode features the most vile and
shocking content I've ever seen on TV
ever most Americans have no idea this is
primetime fair on advertiser supported
basic cable and everyone is paying for
it as part of their program bundle who
knew the Church of Satan could be so
sensitive members of the organization
were reportedly quite unhappy with the
way the Church's late founder was
portrayed on American Horror Story
apocalypse known to his followers as the
black Pope Anton LaVey created the
Church of Satan in the swinging 60s
using the sexual liberation of the day
to his advantage his black masses could
be unusually glitzy Affairs attracting
the likes of Sammy Davis jr. Liberace
and Jayne Mansfield
well one particularly memorable scene in
American Horror Story apocalypse
features lebay portrayed by actor Carlo
rota committing a human sacrifice
suffice to say some Satanists were
seriously steamed in a tweet posted to
the Church of Satan's official Twitter
account the organisation said Anton
LaVey didn't believe in Christ or an
antichrist and sacrifice plays no role
in Satanism lazy writers appropriated
his name and image for their devil
worship drivel which is um
and boring in the sixth episode of Kult
the seventh season of American Horror
Story a crazed cult leader played by
Evan Peters stages a massacre at his own
rally it would be a divisive scene in
the best of times but the episode aired
shortly after a real-life shooting on
the night of October 1st 2017 the
deadliest mass shooting in modern
American history took place in Las Vegas
the AHS episode featuring the bloody
rally scene aired on October 10 in
reaction to the tragedy the violent
sequence was re-edited and significantly
toned down but it was still a
controversial moment of television the
night the episode aired the AV club's
Molly Horan wrote the need to edit out a
moment of violence that now feels all
too real is all the more chilling when
you consider colt is acting as a giant
metaphor and some could say as a giant
mirror held up to the post-election era
yeah this was a first Kevin the third
season of American Horror Story featured
what we'll go ahead and call a tender
moment between the witch Queenie
portrayed by Gabourey Sidibe and a
minute are following the episode The
Daily Mail asked its readership is this
the most horrific episode of American
Horror Story yet even diehard fans left
shocked as bestiality takes center stage
while that might be overstating it the
scene is a bit much you just want it
loved and that makes you a beast
even if minotaur sex isn't your
particular cup of tea perhaps it's best
to keep an open mind
after all it sounds like Sidibe was
totally down with the scene in fact she
told Parade magazine I knew to say guess
and to step out with faith and trust in
Ryan and his entire production team
I took the Minotaur by the horns hey to
each their own
right check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bells so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]